the Super Bowl champion Philadelphia
Eagles were scheduled to visit the White
House today
and Donald Trump canceled their visit
with in fewer than 24 hours of when it
was scheduled to take place and as it
was only about ten of the players were
going to go to the White House because
many of them just disagree with Trump
over the national anthem controversy and
for other reasons and they were choosing
not to participate in that visit and of
the more than fifty players on the
Eagles only ten of them were going to
attend but Trump canceled it
putting out a statement saying the
Philadelphia Eagles are unable to come
to the White House with their full team
to be celebrated tomorrow they disagree
with their president because he insists
that they proudly stand for the national
anthem hand on heart in honor of the
great men and women of our military and
the people of our country the Eagles
wanted to send a smaller delegation but
the thousand fans planning to attend the
event deserve better
these fans are still invited to the
White House oh boy to be part of a
different type of ceremony one that will
honor our great country pay tribute to
the heroes who fight to protect it and
loudly and proudly play the national
anthem I will be there at 3:00 p.m. with
the United States Marine Band and the
United States Army chorus to celebrate
America Trump is making himself the
person who decides what patriotism is
which is completely antithetical to
everything that the United States as a
country stands for and Trump's
definition of patriotism is
extraordinarily slim for example the
only patriotic thing that can be done
while the anthem plays is to stand there
like a robot with your hand on your
heart anything else is disrespectful
according to Trump this is a
presidential tantrum from a totally
triggered snowflake and the real reasons
that he canceled this thing are number
one it would be embarrassing to have
that picture taken
with only ten players number one number
two it's probably another distracted on
the things that are going on with
Michael Cohen the things that are going
on with Paul manna for it which I'll get
to later in the show that is not good
for Trump and then the other thing
that's just generally weird about this
is that none of the Eagle players sat or
kneeled during last Super Bowl right
he's talking about the Eagles
as if they were doing Mass kneeling
protests or something but they didn't do
that during the Superbowl none of the
Eagles players actually sat or kneeled
none of it makes any sense
yeah Nick Foles their quarterback and
star player of the game I think he's
conservative he's quite religious too so
you'd have to think that Trump would
welcome him at least but apparently not
apparently not and you know I don't
really care about the Eagles being
uninvited but I'm sure that Trump is
will see this and say that's right those
Eagles players they are they refuse to
stand they don't deserve to go to the
White House well they all stood right
but good luck communicating that to the
trumpets and the distraction element
which I'm going to get into is that Paul
Manafort is now suspected of witness
tampering in the Russia investigation it
appears that Michael Cohen could be
getting arrested very very soon and we
just can't underestimate the motivation
of just wanting to distract from the
news here by Donald Trump